pas
les américains choisissent aujourd'hui
leur 41e président bush clinton bush
clinton janvier aux etats-unis direction
des n'entre pas à la maison blanche qui
veut la démocratie américaine a ses
particularités
d'abord il faut savoir qu'un candidat
peut devenir président même si son
adversaire obtient plus de votes
oui oui vous avez bien entendu et c'est
arrivé en 2000 le démocrate al gore
gagne le vote populaire grâce à l'appui
d'un demi million d'américains de plus
que son rival mais c'est le républicain
george w bush qui remporte l'élection
pourquoi parce que ce ne sont pas les
citoyens qui élisent le président
l'élection se joue au suffrage universel
indirect en deux temps d'abord le vote
populaire
les américains de chaque état vote pour
les grands électeurs
ensuite ces derniers élisent le
président plus il ya de gens qui vivent
dans l'état
plus il ya de grands électeurs le
candidat qui obtient une majorité de
votes dans un état reçoit l'appui de
tous les grands électeurs
la course n'est pas serré partout à
certains endroits les démocrates
dominent
ailleurs ce sont les républicains pour
devenir président un candidat doit donc
remporté les grands électeurs dans les
états populeux qui ne sont pas déjà
acquis à l'un des partis les états
pivots comme la fleur et l'ohio et la
pennsylvanie
en 2000 c'est la floride qui a fait la
différence bush l'a emporté par
seulement 500 voix autre critère
important
il faut être né citoyen américain pour
rêver à la maison blanche
avoir au moins 30 50 et vivre aux états
unis depuis 14 ans être associé à l'un
des deux grands partis donnent une
longueur d'avancé et l'histoire montre
qu'être un homme blanc peut aider depuis
1789 tous les présidents sont des hommes
mais ça pourrait changer surtout pour
être président il faut de l'argent
beaucoup d'argent et c'est un peu le far
west
les dons aux candidats et aux partis se
limite à quelques dizaines de milliers
de dollars par citoyen les entreprises
et les syndicats eux n'ont plus le droit
de faire ce genre de contribution depuis
le scandale du watergate
mais grâce à un jugement de la cour
suprême de 2010 ils peuvent verser de
l'argent à des groupes nommés les super
pac
leur but appuyer ou critiquer un
candidat il n'y a aucune limite aux dons
de riches citoyens et des entreprises
il participe à coups de millions au
total l'élection pourrait engloutir de 5
à 10 milliards de dollars
une influence qui minent la démocratie
américaine selon des chercheurs
alors que le ou la meilleure gagne ou
pas date de l'élection 8 novembre